[Music]
this season on i am jazz
two years ago i was on my way to one of
the greatest institutions in the world
but i was actually struggling severely
with mental health issues
all right once it zeros i started binge
eating and i gained weight and more
weight and more weight and now almost
100 pounds heavier here i am today
it's a big old belly oh my god
side view
i'm out of shape be easy on me having
all this extra weight i can't do so many
things with my body that i used to be
able to do
hey
how are you this is my first formal date
with the trans woman
xander is this little ball of
geeky juiciness i don't think i've done
something like this carefree in a while
this is a great first date with an
amazing and beautiful woman you made me
stronger
sandra went ice skating the other day
with hope this beautiful trans woman
xander he gets along very well with
transgender women his dear dear friend
miss peppermint i just wonder if they've
dabbled in the
shirtless xander there he is i don't
know what my relationship with sander is
i've actually went on a date with a
trans woman as well oh oh and there's
chemistry there you know sandra's not
one of my girlfriends if i can't have
sex with the person could i see myself
with someone who's not received um her
bottom surgery yet i'm not sure
a typical morning's breakfast fast food
maybe a doughnut or two and then maybe
two bagels i don't judge her by that i'm
just shocked we're not putting butter on
it right now jazz yeah i know i know you
need to chill right now no you need to
chill even when we think we're doing
something right she falls off the wagon
how much butter did you put on the pasta
put one tablespoon you measure it wait
no no that's not one tablespoon i do
experience fat shaming for my family it
makes me feel really humiliated
come on i need you to get up this isn't
gonna cut it at harvard i'm not going to
be here to get you up at least greg and
i are around to prevent her from
oversleeping what's going to happen when
we're not around you got to really
consider whether you could even go up to
school as long as i get off my lazy ass
then you keep making empty promises
you're like i got this i can do this i'm
going to change i can tell you that it's
different now because it's now or never
no it is now or never at this point
prove it because you're all talk oh my
god
[Music]
you